as Harmony Dylan and farming
so this this works out sorry to
interrupt you guys but uh I really want
to answer that question though because
that's important so so we we were we
were thinking about uh you know Steve
had had a had uh I think another
conflict conflict and uh but I think
it's an opportunity to talk about
Solutions because we talk a lot about
problems we talk a lot about Hope but I
know that harmeet is a potential
solution
hi I will answer that question Ian we
will talk later all right okay because
Jesus is the way the truth and the life
harmeet what's happening
well it's been a pretty busy two-week
campaign for chair of the Republican
National Committee and so uh it's been
pretty non-stop we were just talking
about Jesus Christ and spirituality
right as you were walking out so there's
a lot of uh a lot of things happening
there's a lot of energy yeah the Ian's
had this transformation I was telling
people like we're all of a sudden he's
talking about the importance of God do
you believe in God absolutely what do
you think it is
uh well God is the creator
God is over all of us yeah hermit's face
lower that downwards oh and then uh do
this yes God gives us guidance God gives
us life and God gives us everything
that's worth fighting for in this
country and this world
yeah
let's talk and just in the Christian
view just to answer your question so so
Jesus claimed he was God there is a
misconception that Jesus never did that
he repeated the phrase I am especially
in the Book of John uh the first verse
in the Book of John is in the beginning
was the word the word uh became the Word
was God and the word became flesh this
idea the logos right which is rational
speech which is God made in the image of
God and Jesus coming down in human form
was he took the broken form that we
became after original sin because he
loved us so much to minister alongside
of us to show Miracles to then
eventually die a death he did not
deserve to defeat death so then he could
be raised from the dead and we can have
eternal life now the point is this when
we worship Jesus we're not worshiping
man we're worshiping God that
temporarily became man lived a perfect
life and then gives us eternal life
through what he did for us something we
did not earn nor that we deserve I'm
concerned that a centralized Authority
uh wrote The Storybook that tells us
that he said he was God because I don't
I never met him I don't know no that's
that's fair but it's not a centralized
Authority because we have four different
accounts right from four different
people Matthew Mark Luke and John right
and so what's interesting is they
actually reinforce one another and never
contradict each other the one the most
interesting is actually Luke because
Luke continues his gospel in the book of
Acts and so Luke is writing it to his
benefactor Theophilus lover of God who
paid for him to actually go throughout
the Middle East and saw it himself Luke
was a Doctor Luke was a non-committed
person right he was like there's
something magical Happening Here in the
Middle East and so you're right you've
never met Jesus but my belief is you can
because he is the Living God right so
that you can invite him in your life and
in a moment you can have a spiritual
transformation don't mean to hijack it
too much Tim but that's my that's my
metaphysical View and Jesus will change
your life and you can be transformed in
an instant
let's talk about Solutions sorry let's
talk about Solutions because is running
for RNC chair that's right so what's
going on what's the plan
well I don't think there is a plan
unless we have a change in leadership at
the RNC and that's the problem because
for the last six years
we have lost successively we've lost the
house we've lost the Senate we've lost
the White House and we're losing our
country and the reason that I'm a
republican volunteer and activist and
I'm sure many of you are in this room as
well is because I love this country I
came here as an immigrant when I was two
years old my parents registered as
Republicans when they were
naturalized and you know my whole life
I've fought for these values but I'm
afraid that we have a lot of Republicans
in positions of power today including
elected officials including certainly
some of my fellow Republican activists
who are in it for the wrong reasons who
are in it for ego who are in it for
self-gratification who are happy to be
the controlled failed opposition and
America cannot afford that and so that's
the reason why I'm running because I
think I can do a better job and I think
that we need Vision we need a plan
we need a plan to deal with these
crooked election laws we have to adapt
to overcome them and we need to get rid
of the corrupt consultant class that is
controlling the failure in our party I
pledge to do that at the RNC just really
quick what would you be doing different
right now your your your head right now
what's the first thing you do
well I probably hire some great young
Grassroots activists to handle the voter
registration ballot harvesting yes and
ballot curing and states where it's
legal Scott Pressler is one of the guys
who comes to mind for sure absolutely
the second thing I would do besides
Personnel I would I would do something
like an Elon Musk style come in and say
look are you hardcore about electing
Republicans yes are you hardcore about
Liberty are you hardcore about winning
and if you're not here's your two-week
severance check and don't let the door
hit you okay
um
I would immediately initiate a top to
bottom audit of all Consulting and
vendor contracts at the RNC because from
what I've seen there is a tremendous
amount of back scratching fat waste
self-dealing and generally stuff that
doesn't get Republicans elected so with
those two things that's off to a good
start but then there's policy there's
other things you have to do fundraising
is important we fundraise by abusing our
donors we call them names the puppy will
die if you don't give money
um you know if you don't give money this
person that you like won't get elected
and then we use it for different things
I think that's not ethical it's not
consistent with my values as an attorney
that would stop under me at the RNC
sounds great so this is so important
because what you have to understand is
when the left makes its moves you're
like oh the left the left the left when
the left makes its moves it's making
again I keep saying this word a
provocation when that becomes real is
when the conservatives are like okay
we accept we reify the thing that you
just wanted to do so you know they
passed some horrific policy and when
conservatives are like okay that's just
how it is now they change what it means
to have an election and conservative
that's just how it is now that's when it
becomes real that's when we've actually
given away a piece of our country so
having somebody that's going to get in
there and try to stand up and clean this
mess up this controlled opposition hell
half of them are probably active active
participants not controlled opposition
they're pretending at that point what
you have to be able to do is you have to
get in and get in the way of that
because it's those people accepting it
it's the Republicans rolling over after
Barack Obama passes uh Obamacare they
get in 16 Trump comes in on a mandate to
get rid of Obamacare what do they do
like we tried and then we're we're in
this swamp this is how it works we don't
lose our country until we give away the
peace that they tried to take from us
this is so important and this is why I'm
so enthusiastic about her meet and why
I'm enthusiastic for anyone that's going
to challenge the RNC Mike Lindell
included right and which is this is that
when you lose
you should not be rewarded I know that
sounds so obvious that's the way we
treat our football teams our
corporations or anything functioning and
we should have won the Senate this last
election cycle and the Democrats gained
a senate seat period Kerry Lake should
have received far more support from
National Republican organizations
and she did not
and
look I I'm kind of a subject matter
expert here you know Turning Point USA
we're super blessed we have 150 000
donors many of you give us money and we
are good stewards of that money in fact
we have 100 rating from charity
Navigator and our our fundraising costs
are right near six percent the rnc's
fundraising cost is 40 so when you give
money to the Republican Party only 60
percent goes to programming and then I
have to read they spent 321 thousand
dollars on flowers they spent 17 million
dollars on donor mementos a hundred
thousand dollars on clothing like look
we run an organization we run a really
tight ship that is unacceptable for the
Republican party to be doing it's an
insult to all of you that have donated
to candidates and change is needed
immediately and I think people don't
realize this stuff I mean I don't know a
lot about the inner workings of the RNC
or or the DNC it's only in the past
maybe I don't know half decade or so we
start learning more and more about the
inner workings and now a lot of the
stuff we're learning about what was
going on 300 Grand on
well so let me let me unpack this so
that that shrieking sound you hear from
the building at the RNC is is a lot of
consultants and um staff there jumping
to the defense of the chair and I'm
going to give the benefit of the doubt
she probably knew about some of these
things and thought okay this is business
as usual that's part of the defense is
hey everybody does it and then part of
it is done by her staff uh and you know
including some of these Consultants who
are making themselves rich off of donor
money big dollar and small dollar donor
money but if you're so tone deaf that
you don't realize that 700 000 worth of
flowers over a six year period showing
up on your FEC report when the Democrats
spent one thousand dollars during that
time is problematic and you're defending
that you are totally out of touch okay
and and blaming Trump which is another
line of attack that happened out of the
RNC they said Well when the president is
of your party you pay for all the
mementos you pay for the Easter egg hunt
you pay for the Christmas parties
actually that's a separate line item
that's another five million dollars that
we haven't even talked about five
million dollars of parties and White
House stuff but 300 500 000 or 300 000
worth of the jet expenses happen after
Trump left office so how are you blaming
Trump for that a lot of the flowers a
lot of the limos 300 no 3 million
dollars worth of the donor mementos came
after Trump left office guess what guys
I'm a donor a lot of you are donors do
you want mementos or do you want us to
win elections
so here's here's a question I have
in terms of winning these elections
how do you convince this guy to vote for
a Republican and I have a question
um add to this because Trump was just
brought up today he also officially
endorsed Kevin McCarthy as the head of
the head of the GOP another career
politician which as you can see from the
yeah keep going you don't have to stop
keep going let him hear it let
[Applause]
tuce how do you address it what's your
reaction to this kind of latest news
item well I'm going to say something
which is that if we had done our job at
the RNC and also the leadership of the
other two committees and Republicans had
a large majority in the house we
wouldn't be having this conversation we
wouldn't be having this really awkward
conversation about a five-member margin
the freedom caucus some of them not
being happy and this even being a
conversation we might have been able to
freely elect somebody who was popular
with all of the members but because of
this odd situation that if they don't go
that way a Democrat might win I think
that is sort of the the sort of the only
choice that Republicans have right now
Kevin McCarthy's better than a Democrat
um and so he's from my state so I have
to be you know a little diplomatic uh
that's tough but but you know look I
would say through the years of the last
six years there have been a lot of bad
Personnel choices there's been a lot of
bad choices about who's around the hand
of power and here we are and so I think
we're going to make one more at the RNC
if we just say please sir may I have
some more losing yes I don't want that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time